[Music]
in O this sweet news submitted by Joe
Malin car dealership a guy's homemade
gift for his girlfriend with anxiety is
the sweetest thing ever I thought I
supposed to break up with girls without
anxiety yeah yeah you can't date them
they're crazy
is it a weighted blanket to keep on the
place oh my God if you love that [ __ ]
[ __ ] well I wasn't paying attention
underneath it I can't use that I mean it
is a blanket oh it does have the blanket
quality the exotic but the weighted part
isn't supposedly great oh this is a joke
it's for anxiety yeah is that why Casey
likes to wear a backpack
what's it weighted with chain mail I
have a good question actually what the
Donnie best didn't make a change like
anxiety he bets a microwave thank you
I thought sled balls that doesn't sound
safe to have near your body that's true
anyway so the way Joe wanted to say this
he said it two times nobody heard that
well thank you are you this guy even had
his hand up and she didn't say Joe
malian right okay where is it in Denmark
figuring it out he's faced with that
working home we're working on land it's
in the hearts of people she told me how
to pronounce it and then in my head
while she was telling me how to
pronounce it I was I got [ __ ] stupid
and then I forgot how you told me to
pronounce it well you can't come there
anymore you can't go you're not allowed
all right so this story here is about a
couple and the girlfriend she suffers
from anxiety and she has so she says she
first started having mental health
issues and she was a teenager so her
boyfriend also her name is
Denisha and her boyfriend Riley has been
there to support her and so on their
second anniversary Riley surprised her
with a very thoughtful present with
well first let me show you the couple
and I'll tell you about the present Oh
emotional support cloud that would be a
daddy cool anxiety clowns oh then I had
a false but they are on tour and Nora
that is Niagara Falls so then this is
the thoughtful gift
so he's tree trunks we gave her like a
personalized prescription bottle but
inside there were these what do you call
it affirmations no it's like love pill
so you love pills and then if you open
them it's like all these little messages
of like what idiot if she swallows that
she had a tummy ache or what if you
thought that if she swallows that the
message will be a part of who she is
sure he could be one of those people you
had the ability to make everyone around
you happy for example Oh or there's this
up it's like a fortune cookie but in a
pill form why she takes it she's gonna
get constipated do you think that she
was like this is great but I need xanax
she's like what the [ __ ] is my xanax to
put all these stupid messages in this
mom what if he was trying to prevent her
from taking pills anymore it's go so you
don't need that well you need his love
baby
she's like [ __ ] you I need my [ __ ]
pills
so she's like he's like read this
emotional has no plan has no clue you
should run for Miss Universe because
damn some another one a different one
says be proud of yourself you are
amazing and think of all the things
you've accomplished Noah says you're
positivity is so refreshing and
inspiring I don't know if anyone said
those things to me I'd be like what yeah
I don't think one would help me yeah
you're on a plane you're
hyperventilating
you're first of all that's already a red
flag right your husband comes up to you
and he's like hey you look and he's like
hey Mia won't you turn that frown upside
[Laughter]
what role do these guys live in man it
works on some people but I think for me
I would need very specific things said
about yeah exactly like damn your tits
always look good yeah yeah but this
one's so generic it's really a fortune
cookie works better like wake the [ __ ]
up [ __ ] and I'll show ya why am i
trippin I'm the same way right really
yeah you need like rude awakening
like a bucket of cold water oh yeah
[ __ ] I'm tripping over first of all
problems in the same exact way I love is
the only thing that gets through to me
really why did that Nicki would melt
down even harder oh she's super
sensitive yeah see I'm super sensitive
but to get anything done with me like I
tell my trainer when I do see him like
you need you need to call me a fat
[ __ ] [ __ ] like you need to call me I
thought that no one will ever love if I
don't finish these two rides talking
[ __ ] to you all day that's what I need
like that is what motivates man is it
Gua more [ __ ] no one's gonna love it
what's that works
I'm not opposite I'll crumble so you
like you like this yeah like the romance
cuz I I had a gift once like that when I
turned 21 I got 21 balloons and there
were 21 messages I didn't know him back
then and that each one was like why he
loved me so much and I was like that's
sweet
I didn't feel the same but that was
really fun
you're like if this was someone I really
liked this would have been awesome it's
cuz you're a sweet person no like that
is how you know that someone is truly
genuine if like that [ __ ] melts your
heart where is us we're like now we're
free is true yeah we're more jaded I
think yeah because these scoundrels need
something more in order to feel loved
the optimists and the pessimists like
our lovers over here you know what you
guys need to show for our love is to
subscribe to us we need you
subscribe well we know you love us
that's the only way we feel love from
you I think I'm an optimist but I'm a
practical optimist like where I'm like
this doesn't actually help anything
you're just making yourself feel good
the same way okay that's why you need a
slap you need to stop in the face okay I
think he wants to hate you
yeah he won't though cuz I asked him he
hit me once and he wouldn't was in bed
[ __ ] Robert said the same thing I'm a
big one have you slept I just not Nikki
in the face no see exactly like she told
me the slapper oh my I can't do this
Nikki's never asked me to slap her in
the face okay you're in bed she told me
a slap in the face yeah and I was like
you've been it's such a turn-off when
you're like when person it cuz if I feel
too good about I could not hurt her dude
close your fist well that's not what to
do I'd be so down but one thing that
girls really like those if you ask them
if it's okay every three seconds is this
okay see see how they're blushing dude
you know thank you man oh yeah yeah I'm
hooking it up for probably you'll see is
it okay okay but yeah if you thought
that this would help Nikki though you
wouldn't do it oh that wouldn't help
Nikki that's all we're know if it would
or anything that would help her yeah of
course yes she has anxiety yeah big time
who would help her just usually I got a
hugger pretty hard and then I gotta
breathe with her I try to match her
breathing when she's like having a panic
attack is she like gels with your
breathing and you take over does that
look like when you try to match her come
on Joe yeah yeah yeah please oh please
oh I could see how this is working
awesome I see it okay I feel good too
relax slow my breathing down to match
her never tried magic someone's
breathing like if Roberts sleeping next
to me and I try and match his after like
the fifth one I forget how to breathe
like my mom would hold yeah no charlie
Matt you're good I'll do it with my
daughter I'll do it with Robert when you
sleep eh and Audrey too fast oh yeah
they breathing when they're sleeping
they breathe too slow I'm I will say
sometimes because I have much higher
lung capacity than her sometimes I'm
trying to do it but I'm like oh [ __ ] I'm
not getting up here myself I'm trying to
slow it down something all [ __ ] so I
start breathing in through my nose you
just pass out it's tough oh yeah I
remember trying to match Isaac when he
was a baby but like his tiny baby Blum's
and he breathes so fast I felt the same
like I knew more air she's got bird
lungs oh my god
oh yeah so we're talking about this
couple here they say that they love
making each other DIY gifts but this one
has been like the best one yet and she
cried a lot
she posted it on Facebook and that's
where I went viral cool that's very
sweet
yeah like the time I feel like if this
was a room full of normal people and oh
so cute a room full of scoundrels yeah
then that's half of the proposal videos
I watch on YouTube I'm like he's barely
even mentions the chick at all it's
always like showing what a great guy is
and getting the girls
elaborate knows when it come down in a
[ __ ] helicopter and they [ __ ]
squirrel suit that [ __ ] they send the
chick on some crazy [ __ ] scavenger
hunt that takes her forever and she's
obviously like over it and then yeah
it's some grand gesture that's being
filmed the whole time so that he can
look tight and then at the end of it she
always has to do the same thing
I don't like the proposal videos where
the girl like immediately just goes for
the ring meets afore she goes yeah yeah
I'm just like yeah exactly I'm just like
weird god you don't deserve what does
that mean what do you think what do you
think that that's going through their
head her in her head she's like I mean
she got a rock that's that's all she
cares about
I fell to like hugging him first and
like letting him put it on her like they
just immediately a ball and then put it
on their hand did you wait to look at
the rock we like don't look at it find
it I almost ate it
why what happened you have to like be
like no stop eating this it's in here
and then like he picked it out is it
okay no it was the last course at this
really nice dinner we went to eat at
Smith in Chicago and the chef brought
out an extra dessert for us and there
was these like dried things around this
like cloth in the middle but I thought
the cloth was like you know part of the
dish so I grabbed the dried things and I
started putting it in my mouth and I
realized oh these are literally just
dried twigs not chocolate or anything so
I'm like wiping my tongue with the
napkin and then I go to take another one
I'm like well I guess it wasn't that bad
and then he like grabs my hand out of
the way you think that's not edible look
in there and I'm like it doesn't even
look that good like can we get the check
he picks the ring out he didn't even get
on the knee he didn't say will you marry
me do you want to marry me because he
was so frustrated cuz you're such a pain
in the ass about it oh my god poor guy
absolutely an extra dessert I blame the
chef we're putting it in so damn deep
that's true
[Music]